welcome to this video deform hmm so some
something else I could try I don't want
to have a completely offbeat position on
one let's it's difficult maybe okay it
doesn't want to be noni okay and then
the English symmetrical English then
let's let's set up on this kind of
position all is a surprising because the
five now is technically technically
interesting okay so I wanna pawn on c4
internet it's always a bit tricky oh
yeah I was threatening look 28 I thought
this was a serious threat but he ignored
it just played Roxy one
aha so I 'if I've he's intending to play
95 right hmm
595 home yeah
so let's just develop him
III sm and 90 booth
so what now yeah if either still 95 but
it's a bit different now D 595 CD 584 d
takes c6 and he's rattling detail RC six
takes be seven okay though I cannot
cannot really do that so Nigel's I guess
95
yeah maybe 95 trying to get the sea for
porn
yeah these kind of positions are
sometimes really tricky because white
may lose some a pawn on the queenside
like here the sea porn but the bishop on
g2 is so strong always attacking b7 idea
just compare g2 to c 8 it's a very odd
there's something lost on the queenside
and it's it's not such a big problem
because you have all the activity so
take see for now or not hmm yeah I
rather have some some more development
and it's hard for him to to cover the
weakness long term anyway
one idea of this is Bishop c6 possibly
but of course always need to watch out
for 95 sacrifices so Bishop see 695 is
this no it's not working but this means
that this is a good move getting rid of
the the bishop on g2 SM is a huge issue
okay checking with the pawn is
threatening c5 but otherwise really
ridiculous right it's not so ridiculous
one idea is c5 and night CCL and Queen
c6 also okay but this is this a simple
and good and again I'm threatening me
five now winning a piece maybe a sub
technical way around that so it's not a
piece win like 95 95 CD 555 queen bee
three you have a no it's a piece
let's just a piece okay so is getting
rook at peace for the for the Queen but
I can also think about Quincy six just
step briefly yeah okay let's let's take
this check it's a it's never going to be
enough absolutely not look the ATM I
need to get rid of one look here the
five porn is not not hanging really i
think if you take stakes but should be 5
22 looks like I'm invading with a nice
effect
check all right so he doesn't believe it
sir it's an issue after Queen d2 he
needs to play em the really ugly wolf
king of one yeah anyway if this is the
right move anyway I need to do that and
then probably ninety form okay I can
also just take here but I think I'm I
need to I need to activate the night is
nice only form prepares f6 can have
seven and a key I can always take on a
295 to d3 as another idea
yeah maybe we should should play
something like Bishop deform okay
secured the pawn ok I want a bit of
space form for my king so simply useful
and now maybe Queenie to run I'd like to
have an additional porn him
50 seconds ok
should I just take it in the am come on
it's it's a bone I can play b62 together
like I just forgot that you can take hmm
check
check
check
now I need to make sure that I'm not in
some crazy mating net the a bonus is the
winner I am try morning check check DRA
offered check no it's not it's not
really a check check check check check
check game Quran how many move is he
going to make what the heck what I
wasn't so sir ahead I had six again
three check and one on boy is premiering
he's some more catching up here it
doesn't doesn't show there and now i'm
really curious yeah yeah whatever draw
um-hmm bit disappointing when you're
basically winning from 15 or something
yeah okay though the thing to remember
is that this is just a just a big
mistake we call ot5 and black is already
clearly better you need to this position
you basically need to sacrifice the pawn
or play Queen d3 which is very meek but
you can do that like
yeah this is a mistake and black is
clearly better this is the only move
that that doesn't sacrifice a pawn after
this I'm threatening 95 so wyd needs to
take and this is just just very
comfortable in in this position that the
best is just to sacrifice this this line
this is some quite good compensation for
white leading to too complicated game
and this is just better for black in
various ways but then I think this was
pretty okay I mean like it's just just
very comfortable here alright thanks for
watching